alors pour faire respecter la
distanciation social à bord des avions
c'est assez facile il faut distinguer le
court le moyen et le long courrier
en ce qui concerne le court et le moyen
courrier
l'essentiel des avions qui sont utilisés
pour ce transport sont des airbus a320
a319 et a321 ou des boeing 737
ces avions ont trois places de front sur
la gauche et trois places de front sur
la droite ils ont donc six places de
front pourrait faire respecter la
distanciation sociale il suffit de ne
pas occuper le siège du milieu qui de
toute façon est un siège que les
passagers n'aime pas ce qui veut dire
que le remplissage des avions serait un
tiers inférieur à ce qu'il aurait pu
être si l'avion était plein les
compagnies aériennes disent qu en
dessous de 50% tout remplissage elles ne
peuvent pas être rentable or là on est à
66 entre 66 et 70 % de taux de
remplissage ce qui devrait leur
permettre d'être rentable mais il faut
faire une différence très importante
entre les low cost et les compagnies
traditionnelles
parce que les unes et les autres ont des
structures de prix qui sont très
différentes les low cost quand vous
faites un aller-retour en fait vous
achetez deux allers simples et l l'agglo
causse ne tient pas compte du fait que
vous restiez un moment pas longtemps peu
etc
elle vous vend deux allers simples les
compagnies traditionnelles ventes
essentiellement des allers-retours donc
elles savent quand leurs passagers
partent et surtout quand sur le même
billet le passager revient
et ça ça leur permet de faire une autre
type de différenciation sociale
ça leur permet de savoir qui part pour
loi ses loisirs et qui part pour le
travail et ça ça une très grande
importance sur le prix pourquoi parce
que les gens qui partent pour le loisir
sont très dépendants du prix est à
quelques euros près is here on vers une
autre compagnie aérienne
en revanche ceux qui voyagent pour le
travail on privilégie toujours la
fréquence et le fait de pouvoir rentrer
le plus vite possible et ils sont moins
dépendants du prix donc les compagnies
traditionnelles aujourd'hui quand vous
passez une par exemple une nuit du
samedi au dimanche sur place ou que vous
restez trop rare à jour sur place le
tarif que vous payez pour un aller
retour est très inférieur à celui que
payera quelqu'un qui part seront sans
travail pour une journée ce qu'on
appelle un aller-retour journée ou pour
rester un jour ou deux jours donc les
compagnies traditionnelles vont pouvoir
d'une part se défaire un peu des
passagers loisirs qui sont les moins
rentables et se concentrait plus
facilement sur les passagers business
qui sont les plus rentables
les compagnies low cost comme elle vante
de la deux années simple ne savent pas
qui est le loisir et qui est business et
comme l ont fait toute leur
communication sur le prix et pas sur le
service
elles ont probablement beaucoup plus de
mal à tenir la rampe face à ces
nouvelles configurations en ce qui
concerne le long courrier les classes
business des compagnies traditionnelles
air france lufthansa british airways
sans déjà équipés pour la
différenciation sociale c'est à dire que
vous êtes dans votre coque vous avez
votre siège
et vous avez personne à côté ou si vous
avez quelqu'un côté on peut mettre un
rideau ou un paravent donc les
compagnies traditionnelles savent que
s'ils arrivent à vendre l'ensemble de la
classe business
l'avion est déjà rentable et après ça
elles vendent les classes arrière
c'est-à-dire la classe premium ou la
classe économique pour pas cher parce
que la business a déjà rompu à déjà fait
son rôle de rentabiliser l'avion et donc
qu'est ce qui va se passer c'est qu'en
économie quand les compagnies
traditionnelles vont mettre un siège sur
deux
elles vont avoir des mauvais taux de
remplissage mais si elles ont réussi
avant de l'avant de l'avion elles seront
moins rentables mais seront toujours
rentable